Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to.
Oh, I don't know.
How about, um, how about Ryan from Dallas,
Texas?
Ryan, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Hello? David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Thank you for taking the time.
So I was just wondering like, you know, you
have a lot of these extreme ideologies being
pushed by the right to stir up the group of
people on the left who don't follow the news
as much, so they don't know the specific details
on certain topics.
For instance, like the like the Dylan Mulvaney
saying they were saying that he came out or
she came out, you know, saying that she was
a spokesperson for tamp for tampons or something
like that.
And it was just like that wasn't even what
happened.
Apparently, she has said that she kept one
on her sometimes or whatever, you know, for
a friend or whoever may need it or whatever.
And so I just sometimes it's difficult because
I have friends who, you know, are on the left,
but they they they don't actually follow the
news.
Like, I had a friend who mentioned that, oh,
Kamala Harris hasn't been, you know, in the
public since she came into office.
And so, you know, she hasn't been seen.
Speaker 1: In public at all.
Speaker 3: Yes.
And even though you can follow her on YouTube
weekly and so I just I don't know.
I just kind of want to hear your thoughts
on that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's a I have a lot of conversations
with people where they they'll say things
like, listen, you know, I grew up in a Democratic
family, but like, this woke stuff, it's really
got to end.
Then I'll go, Oh, okay.
Like, what do you mean?
And they go, No, it's just, you know, it's
crazy what's happening with with with Antifa.
And it's just crazy.
It's like everything's so woke.
You can't do anything anymore.
I go, Oh, like what?
What can't you do?
They're going to just it's like.
It's just the it's the environment.
It's the feeling of like, you just can't everything
you say, you're going to get in trouble for
nobody.
Oh, like, what is it you're trying to say
that you think you'll get in trouble for?
Well, no, it's not me, but like, you know,
and you'll spend 10 minutes like this and
it goes nowhere.
It goes nowhere, and it still lives someone
who's voting for Biden or whatever.
But it is kind of disappointing.
Speaker 3: Yes.
And and I'm actually kind of worried because
although I think that Bernie has done a I
would say a decent job as president, I think
that him being 80 and running for president
again, I think he's only doing it just so
that he can defeat Trump because maybe, you
know, the Democratic Party are afraid of Trump
winning.
But I don't think that Biden running at this
age, at his age, is actually going to be good
for the Democratic Party.
As far as interest.
Speaker 1: No, I don't think it's going to
it's it's not inspiring.
It doesn't generate it doesn't generate interest
in the way that you're sort of talking about.
I agree with you completely.
And, you know, there are people who write
to me and go, David, I don't know that Biden
can defeat Trump.
If you look at polling, if Biden can't, I
don't know that anyone else in particular
can either.
I mean, Trump has a significant level of support
in this country, as shocking as that may be.
I don't know who can beat Trump.
Speaker 3: Yes.
And I have one last quick question.
I know previously you had mentioned that you
weren't a Democrat, but I saw on your video
the other day, you mentioned you were a progressive
social Democrat.
So I was just trying to confirm which which
it was.
Speaker 1: So.
Social Democrat, the D is lowercase.
It's not a party affiliation.
So I'm not a capital D Democrat.
I'm not a member of the Democratic Party.
I don't I'm not a I'm an independent voter.
From a party affiliation standpoint, progressive
social democracy is an ideology, not a party.
The D is lowercase, you know what I'm saying?
Speaker 3: Yes, yes, yes.
Speaker 1: That's that's I think that is basically
the clearest explanation.
Speaker 3: That will help me from my next
conversation with my friend.
So thank you.
Speaker 1: All right, Ryan, thanks for the
call.
All right.
There goes Ryan.
Let's go.
I mean, against my better judgment.
Let's go to Donald from Palm Beach, Florida.
I'm a little worried about this.
Donald from Palm Beach, Florida.
You're on the air.
Okay.
Donald from Palm Beach, Florida, Clearly it
was a joke.
They bailed.
Very, very funny joke.
Let's go next to actually let's try once more.
Donald from Palm Beach, are you actually trying
to get on what's going on?
You're not getting afraid now or whatever
joke you were going to do.
Yeah, they are.
All right, well.
They're gone.
How about let's go to Louie from New Brunswick.
Louis.
From New Brunswick.
Welcome to the program.
Speaker 4: Thank you, Dave.
It's so good to be on your program.
Pleasure.
I just want to chime in on something that
the the last question, Ryan.
I was I noticed as well that people were throwing
around the word, woke quite a bit at work
and just just around.
And I realized that it meant vastly different
things to different people.
So I started asking people, can you just help
me understand what that word means?
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 4: And I was a little facetious.
And like, I noticed, like the older generation
talked about like being hyper hypersensitive,
taking offense and it was like, you know,
pejorative like, oh, I don't like woke like
it's going woke all over the place.
I asked young people, especially people, especially
like people might identify as being a minority.
And they were like, no, it actually has a
lot to do with just understanding the historical
context of of, you know, of historical wrongs.
And so I think there's a huge problem.
I think that the right really weaponized the
word.
So it's almost a you know, it's like a bad
word in a sense.
Speaker 1: I'd go further.
I mean, so first of all, Louis, I have a YouTube
clip called Something along the lines of they
don't even know what woke means.
Where I talk about a lot of this stuff in
detail, I would go further than to say that
they have weaponized the word woke.
The right has actually perverted the word
woke because really what woke originally meant
when the left used it seriously.
Now it's pretty facetiously used, but when
the left used the word woke, what was meant
was I'm aware of problems in society, some
of which are more structural than about the
individual.
And I would like to find solutions to those
problems like that.
That's that was really the meaning of woke
when it was a sincere term.
And it's been weaponized and perverted from
the right by the right.
I don't really know anyone seriously using
it.
Like sometimes I'll joke around, like friends
will say to me, someone will recommend the
TV show, for example, or a movie, and then
someone else in the conversation will describe
the plot and someone will say, sort of tongue
in cheek.
Ooh, sounds like it might be a little too
woke for me.
And it's a joke.
You know, everybody.
The term has now become one that I don't know
if people on the left actually using in a
serious way.
Speaker 4: Interesting.
Yeah, because the right definitely uses it
in a serious way.
I got another question for you.
A couple months ago you had one of my favorite
authors, Jefferson Morley, on the program,
wondering if he'd be able to bring them back
any time soon.
Speaker 1: Well, you know, we don't tend to
have authors on more than once a year, but
I'm glad to have a mine again in the future
for sure.
Speaker 4: He does a great subsequent talks,
you know, primarily about investigating the
JFK assassination.
He's really up to date on on on disclosure
coming from the government.
Okay.
So I've got a question today.
Nasser actually held a public forum on their
investigations of UAP.
So like, I guess that's like the modern word
for UFOs.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 4: So here's my question to you.
A Jefferson Morley would pause, and I think
a lot of people agree that there's still a
lot of disclosure that hasn't happened in
terms of the JFK assassination case.
Now, there's a lot of stuff going on in the
mainstream media, like from USA Today about
UFO disclosure.
So here's my question.
Do you feel like this is is this like an endemic
issue in our in our modern society where there's
a lot of information that's being withheld
from the public?
Speaker 1: I don't know that it's a particularly
modern issue.
There's a long history of the classification
of documents.
There are entire books written about whether
there is overclassification.
I did an interview about it.
I don't believe it's specific or conspiratorial
to Uup's and Kennedy is what I would say.
But there are other people who have far more
to say about that issue than I do.
Speaker 3: So.
Speaker 4: David, during the lockdown period,
my wife and I really enjoyed watching your
show and YouTube live.
It was it was almost therapeutic.
So I just want to say thank you.
You're doing a great job.
Thanks for taking my call, Louie.
Speaker 1: Thank you so much.
Very much.
Appreciate that.
That will do it for live calls today.
Will do more calls.
Don't worry.
We'll do it again.
We'll take a quick break and be back with
much more on the Friday show right after this.